[Música]
decidi contar hoje uma história uma
história de amor
uma história que transformou e
transforma dean diariamente a minha vida
eu trabalho viajando muito mais ou menos
uns sete anos atrás eu arrumar a minha
mala a noite esperando meu filho chegar
em casa ele tinha ido numa festa e ele
me mandava mensagem atribuindo já tô
indo eu queria que ele viesse eu ia
ficar com saudade era mais uma semana
fora e ele não vinha não vinha hockey
não tinha o que fazer ele estava bem fui
dormir acordei uma minha mala encontra
uma carta na pia do banheiro e nessa
carta estava escrito uma desculpa eu
estava numa festa e eu tava afim de um
garoto
eu queria ficar mais na festa para ver
se rolava alguma história com ele na
hora que eu li ke ha garoto eu falei
claro que é um erro não é para cima
negócio é para baixo
a garota só pode ser a garota quando eu
li aquela carta eu falei nossa meu filho
é gay
eu chorei muito muito foram dias de
chorar e chorando porque tinha uma
história pronta pra ele ele é casar e
ele é ter filhos ele porque eu achava
que eu era uma mãe incrível
lógico que não tinha votado no roteiro
que ele seria profissionalmente estava
liberado para essa parte aqui não
eu voltei de viagem e aí marcamos uma
conversa fora de casa eu estava com
muito medo daquela conversa
essa foi a primeira de muitas conversas
de contações de história começa as
fáceis de fez seis tensas intensas
profundas superficiais mas conversas que
contavam sobre nossas histórias passou
um tempo encontro ele no lugar eu vindo
de um estado ele do outro e ele então
vem no meio da galera e olha para ele e
vejo ele de unhas vermelhas cumpridas
na hora que eu vi isso eu falei ah não
agora além de tudo ainda vai mostrar
para o mundo a história dele como assim
de um misto de vergonha de raiva de
atrapalhamento e aí ele chega eu devia
estar com uma cara horrível e ele falou
vamos lá eu sou um aluno incrível
adoro aprender tenho amigos gostou de me
relacionar é tem um caminho espiritual
algo me guia
entendo o mundo numa investigação que é
uma fala sua investigar entendendo o
mundo a partir das injustiças estou
buscando isso
nessa investigação eu estou descobrindo
que eu costuro que eu danço que o canto
minha mãe
o que mais você quer de mim nesse dia eu
falei meu filho é gay
meu filho é gay e eu não tenho
direito de silenciar a história dele
isso não é uma questão isso é uma
realidade e é uma realidade que precisa
caber no mundo que precisa pertencer a
um mundo
essa história é a história de muita
gente
ainda bem
essa é uma história que precisa ser
contada para que essa narrativa faça o
mundo se revisitar aos 36 anos eu fui
chamada para fazer um projeto chamado a
justiça restaurativa e eu nossa mês que
estão fazendo um projeto de justiça só
psicóloga
eu entendia que a justiça era algo que
acontecer só no tribunal e não a justiça
restaurativa me trouxe princípios e
valores para eu entender as contações de
história precisam ter lugar no mundo
a justiça restaurativa é uma mudança de
paradigma é a possibilidade da gente ter
outra percepção das relações dessa
justiça entrar aqui
aqui dentro não depositar e ninguém a
responsabilidade de revisitar histórias
justiça restaurativa é uma injustiça que
se faz sentindo entendendo quais são as
nossas reais necessidades
a justiça restaurativa tem um proceder
em ti
ela senta em círculo para que as pessoas
contem suas histórias e quando eu conto
a minha história
essa história se encontra com a história
do outro
a história que eu contei para vocês da
minha relação amorosa e transformadora
com meu filho fernando
muitas vezes é uma história que termina
com muita violência
o silêncio é uma violência muitas vezes
o silêncio faz com que as pessoas não
possam ser elas a gente tem muitas
histórias de justiça das mais suaves as
mais graves quando lá atrás eu não
acreditava na justiça está na ativa
nesse caminho de implementação de 13
anos que eu faço
em muitos lugares em muitos espaços
eu vejo o quanto é necessário e urgente
que a justiça esteja presente esteja que
conosco nessa conversa
a justiça tem que estar dentro das
nossas casas porque nós somos seres
humanos que nos relacionamos a justiça
restaurativa é uma filosofia é uma forma
de eu trazer para a cena num espaço
protegido o conflito o que eu sinto
diante de um conflito
o então eu lhe dar com uma violência
certa vez eu sentei em círculo com dois
irmãos não tinha tentado matar outro ou
facadas
nós conseguimos depois de vários
encontros passarmos pelas etapas que
fazem com que as pessoas pratiquem
violência justiça tem a ver com
consciência
a justiça tem a ver com liberdade e
justiça não tem a ver com aprisionamento
e controle de comportamento
nem dos nossos corpos nas nossas ações
então contar histórias é libertar se
libertar
no lugar de se conectar com aquilo que é
o sua verdade o seu sentimento e que por
vezes precisa ser transformado no dia
que eu entendi que meu filho era gay e
lidei com isso ele deixa o meu
preconceito eu me achava incrível como
eu disse eu ali
transformei a mim transformei a ele e
nenhum dos dois
desistiu de si próprio nem do outro
quando a justiça estar ativa chega na
minha vida
ela chega com o convite sobre o que é
dar vez e voz às pessoas o que é criar
ambientes aonde a gente possa trazer a
nossa visão de mundo
quando a gente pensa em situações
injustas
o que a gente está trazendo são nossas
histórias
quando a gente está num ambiente
protegido para lhe dar um a vida com as
relações
a gente pode a partir daquele encontro
produzir um reencontro e
fundamentalmente transformar um ato
conflituoso violento num ato criativo de
aprendizado
quando a gente trabalha na lógica de uma
justiça que é do humano
a justiça não pertence a nenhuma
instituição
por isso eu volto a ter poder um poder
sobre a a minha ação de transformação a
violência
sobre o outro e na história que eu
contei pra vocês eu sendo mãe eu poderia
ter tido este poder e este poder teria
provavelmente causado muitos danos na
pessoa que eu mais amo
então a gente tá aqui falando de uma
justiça que está presente nessa sala
quando a gente fala das relações
a gente está falando de uma justiça que
transborda na hora
falo das minhas fortes emoções
quando fui percebendo que o mundo não
tinha espaço para as histórias foi
quando eu também fui percebendo que os
espaços que não se conta a história são
os passos mais violentos
eu também fui percebendo que cada vez
que a gente tem mais pressa nas relações
a gente consegue no ar que é o tempo da
nossa subjetividade que é o tempo as
nossas humanidades e pensar justiça é
pensar talvez lá atrás nas comunidades
ancestrais dos povos de primeira nação
que se reunissem para resolver suas
questões junto e aí nessa resolução
energia uma solução que podia ser
preventiva
podia ser resolutiva ou podia
transformar essa convivência justiça
transforma é nos povos de primeira nação
sabedoria são pessoas têm doria os a
abes são aqueles e aquelas
sabem contar suas histórias mas a partir
da juíza de que aprenderam
então se a gente quer viver e é possível
de uma outra forma
produzindo conscientemente paz
a gente vai precisar visitar as nossas
sondas os nossos fazeres violentos
a gente vai precisar de deus e conceitos
a gente vai precisar tirar os véus de se
olhar que a gente tem de que eu não sou
preconceituoso eu não sou violento e eu
não sou injusto eu desde que me entendo
por gente gosta de gente mas mesmo assim
eu pratico violência e às vezes as mais
sutis contar parece é e nesse lugar
contar histórias daquilo que é mais
desafiador é e neste lugar de
consciência
então é eu entendi que eu precisava
trazer pro meu fazer e aí foi quando eu
fundei o laboratório de convivência um
fazer que assume que a gente tá ainda
experimentando muitas coisas para
aprender a conviver que a gente ainda
não sabe conviver mas que nós temos
potência para conviver que a gente tem
condições sim de transformar aquilo que
é desafiador ao aprendizado que é
inspirador se esso e que a gente dentro
de nós tudo o que nos faz produzir
injustiças mas também tem as respostas
para
produzir a paz tem 13 anos eu caminho
por esse país por estradas por lugares
buscando implementar estar ativa como
uma política pública a partir do ser
humano
eu já contei muitas histórias mas hoje
eu fiz questão de chamar meu filho que
está sentada aqui para contar essa
história
agradecendo essa história e reconhecendo
a potência dessa história transforma
minha vida transforma sua vida mas
transforma a vida de muitas pessoas que
não tendo coragem de contar essas
histórias pra que essas histórias
verdadeiramente pertencem ao mundo para
que a gente não viva um mundo de
histórias racistas e discriminatórias
preconceituosas de violência contra as
pessoas e os irmãos e para terminar a
minha fala eu peço fernando que termina
o meu lado porque a gente não histórias
sozinho
[Aplausos]
[Música]
foi um caminho gente foi um caminho
longo e o que eu posso dizer dessa
história toda é que é uma escolha vez
caminho é uma escolha você aceitar e
você fazer as pessoas que você ama te
aceitar e também é então quando você faz
essa escolha não tem volta
porque só tem ou acerto ou erro né é o
que a gente quer o acerto
e hoje eu posso dizer com certeza que a
minha história a minha mãe é o maior
acerto que eu tenho na minha vida porque
foi muito difícil os encontros e os
desencontros foram inúmeros e durante
anos eu sei que é uma palestra de 18
minutos mas a história durou anos pra
gente conseguir se acertar no sentido de
eu também entender o preconceito dela
que existia entender e aceitar esse
preconceito porque eu fui criado de uma
forma por ela que ela não foi criada
pela mãe dela ea força que eu e ela
tivemos faz a nossa relação ser única
forte e proveitosa para nós dois na mãe
sim
[Música]